I know you like jazz but you look like
rock and roll man you're so cool well
coming from you a high praise indeed
I'm just saying you look fantastic oh
thank you I never noticed these tattoos
before I have 15 really
I got it do you think I have any tattoos
I would say no why I don't know you seem
like you'd be like that feels like
forever and that's probably a bad idea
which it is sometimes but then you just
change your tattoos I guess so you are
so great
let me look at you you're so grant
Riemann and I so respect everything you
are and what you do yes and I scared
everyone not me you were great you were
vicious you're very into it you were a
force of nature
you got between me and Jen Jennifer
Garner we had we were both beasts you
were proposed full of beans you were
great but Richard Curtis who does those
is great it's a very yeah Red Nose Day
beautiful yeah he raises him do lots and
lots of money and helps people in a very
I know he started in the UK and then it
came over here and I've been a part of
it a couple times and it's a really cool
it's a way to have fun and see
celebrities make an idiot of themselves
and he raised money for kids it's really
cool yeah it's really cool you know I
know him he wrote the script you know he
did four rings in a funeral yeah and
Notting Hill his and Love Actually his
first movie that he wrote was the tall
guy then that was me I was the tall guy
and Emma Thompson was her first movie
I'm tough so it's a love love story yeah
look up tall guy yeah I love her too oh
yeah that's okay I haven't seen that one
yeah yeah I want to see that I love
Richard Curtis well both of us have a
lot in common I was reading your prenup
you know it's like okay we have kids
around the same age what and I both have
kids named River we love sunflowers were
into music we're both thespians I'm just
kidding I can't ask
I'm not and I hate it but but I had do
but um no we have both kids named river
that's random yours is a boy right yes I
love River for a girl - I love
androgynous names yeah me too
our River yeah I mean riot yeah look at
that wait a minute now those are boys
those are two boys I know but the curls
are great all the time people go I love
your daughter's because we haven't cut
their hair look at that that's River
there oh my gosh and that's charlie
ocean and that's Charlie's because
you're the coolest kid names where did
you get charlie ocean you're known
around these parts like everybody heard
you were coming here and all the ladies
they call you as daddy do you know what
his daddy is not exactly
we actually don't either like I didn't
know what is that he was either so I had
to get some of my staff to tell us okay
Kayla where you at daddy what does daddy
well for whatever reason Kelly kids
today feel like being a dad is lame for
some reason they think dad jokes are
lame dad jeans are lame but the fact of
the matter is there's nothing lame about
being a dad and a dad is a man who might
be a little bit more seasoned but it
still has that youthful zest you can
feel that's what disease coming from and
Jeff is a prime example of this I mean
check out this fit y'all have seen his
Instagram Zadi all day long
[Applause]
like a milk is that what that is for
like women or is that not daytime he
probably can't say that you can't say
that on daytime jab that's just crude
I'm so sorry what do you think about
being a daddy I like being a dad like
I'm still trying to enter understand the
definition I think I think I get it I
think it's complimentary it's very very
much but I like being a daddy that
opened up a whole new world world yeah I
thought I loved my life and then I had
kids being pregnant with them was
horrible but afterwards I'm straight
yeah I want to hear about all of that
but I Simon watching the show I saw your
kids on the show when they came out ran
to you and hug you I started to get
weepy just and just seeing it they're so
cute yeah my daughter is definitely I'm
gonna have to like I'm gonna have to
Kendrick Lamar humble that one down yeah
she's yeah she's so I love it she's bold
but she's never met a stranger and
definitely loves attention
really I don't know where she gets it
from job all the artists I do this real
for wait a minute wait a minute this her
teeth whose cheese the answer that's
Beyonce cheese
yeah Beyonce's me I did it for her so me
she's got a little tiny teeth I mean
look how tiny well she's a delicate
creature look at my big horse teeth
compared
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at them and look how sparkly and
white madonna gets here it's the Madonna
gap because I feel cooler because she
she wants it too because your show is
awesome it's such a cool idea the world
according to Jeff Goldblum and tell
everybody what the kind of premise of it
is well it's on Disney Plus and week I
on whether we did they just by the way
renewed us for a second season is the
first time I'm mentioning it publicly
[Applause]
we're gonna do a bunch more this next
year I had a great time shooting them
they are me following you know familiar
objects like flowers or or coffee we did
we did sneakers barbecues RVs cosmetics
jewelry different things everyday things
but we find the interesting complicated
surprising things about them and then I
move in and out of the aficionados on
the subject and and have an experience
but may give way to my personal
associations and a personal epiphany or
revelation of some kind and also and
also some facts about it that may be
interesting and some abstractions and
larger ideas what do you think of that
[Applause]
go to Texas we were in Houston a Johnny
Dangs Grill Emporium like those people
they gave me a grill they made a grill
for me I have a grill that I didn't wear
today but I have a grill did you post a
picture of it yeah I think there's been
a picture of it oh you got to get in the
pool
yeah yes so I got in oh I went to raging
waters there were thing I got into a
sensory deprivation pool but I also went
to Texas I went to Houston to the NASA
neutral buoyancy lab and where there's
the largest pool there so that they can
practice because the astronauts sir whom
I met
all of them and women who were at the
end of their training or gonna be
astronauts they can go in the pool for
like six hours at a time in all their in
their stuff because at the bottom of it
there's a replica of the International
Space Station's
I love your show that's interesting
[Applause]
Hollywood game night and you said oh
yeah I work at this band and so where
did mildred Schnitzer orchestra come
from because that's pretty specific it's
unusual the because you're trying to
come up with a name for your maybe we
can help her in the next two minutes how
we came up with our thing was there was
a lady who lived near us in Pittsburgh
where I grew up and she was a friend of
my mom's Charlotte her name was Mildred
schnitzer so when we had to do it I said
hey that's an interesting name she was a
great lady - she lived to me your name
is my band well I did I did we like that
so I said Mildred sister Orchestra [ __ ]
online my favorite one is because every
time I say give it up for mommy and
y'all and so they call him my band y'all
okay that may not Mildred Smith sir I'm
aware well I like that well if you have
an interesting person who was a friend
or whose name you're like you could call
it that
but maybe no basic friend names how
about hey but you're gonna go to Las
Vegas and kind of be doing new things
how about how about Kelly do you think
it'll be Kelly Clarkson Andy something
and my banjo oh yeah so maybe Kelly
Clarkson and the Wayne Newton Orchestra
or the Danny Gans you know Danny Gans no
he was the entertainer of the year for
many years right Danny Gans Orchestra
but we were just talking today well just
in conversation when you find yourself
talking just today I was talking to an
IRA George are a great singer here
you'll see in a second um and she was
saying oh I couldn't go to my husband's
taking care of the kids today and he's
on guard the gardening the gardening
committee I said gardening committee
good band I said that's a good band
gardening gardening committee but how
about your initials are Casey yeah shine
band the Kent that's a we thought Casey
in the moonshine ban or Casey in the Sun
burnt band
well that's it that's all I have how
about Casey at the back I'm gonna be
honest with you my favorite is gardening
committee subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going